il ya 500 ans c'est tours qui se situe
au coeur de la vieille ville de lévis
vous savez à défendre les habitants des
invasions venant de l'est devenu un
musée aujourd'hui elle a été transformée
en un atelier de confection de
camouflage destinée à l'armée
ukrainienne ici chaque bout de tissu a
son importance pour tous ceux qui
désirent participer à cet effort de
guerre
conflit a commencé nous avons compris
que nous devions faire quelque chose que
nous pouvions pas rester à la maison et
regarder les nouvelles tout le temps il
nous sommes donc réunis à l'accueil du
centre le bureau est juste ici et nous
avons commencé à fabriquer des filets
dans notre héros nous avions beaucoup de
volontaires puis d'autres organisations
ont commencé à nous appeler et a proposé
dans locaux nous avons beaucoup de
demandes de la part de notre armée alors
nous essayons de les satisfaire tout
en tout nous avons environ 55 endroit
comme celui-ci dans la ville nous
essayons bien de tous nous coordonner
avec d'autres organisateurs pour
partager des vêtements des filets
dans cette tour qui a servi dans le
passé à repousser l'ennemi les habitants
de lviv espère aujourd'hui que tout ce
qui est produit servira à protéger non
seulement la ville met le pays en entier